es ser capaz de entender la inteligencia creando nuestros propios sistemas
que muestren inteligencia como la vemos en la naturaleza.
Las opiniones más populares de IA, vienen de la ciencia ficción y las películas
y yo soy una gran fan de Star Wars.
Pero eso tiende a una visión de la inteligencia muy humana.
Cuando se piensa en un banco de peces
o en una familia de estorninos,
se siente como otro tipo de inteligencia.
Para empezar, cualquier pez es tan pequeño
comparado con el tamaño total del colectivo
que parece que cualquier individuo
tendría un alcance realmente limitado y miope de lo que pasa.
y la inteligencia no trata de individuos
sino de alguna manera de una propiedad del grupo mismo.
En segundo lugar, y lo que que todavía encuentro más notable,
es que sabemos que no hay líderes supervisando estos peces.
En vez de eso, este increíble comportamiento mental colectivo
está emergiendo puramente de las interacciones de un pez y otro.
De alguna manera, estas interacciones o reglas de juego
entre peces vecinos
hacen que todo funcione.
Así que la pregunta para IA se convierte en:
¿cuáles son esas reglas de juego que llevan a este tipo de inteligencia?
y claro, ¿podemos crear la nuestra?
Y eso es lo principal en que trabajo con mi equipo en mi laboratorio.
Trabajamos en ello a través de la teoría,
mirando los sistemas de reglas abstractas
y pensando en las matemáticas de fondo.
También lo hacemos mediante la biología, en conjunto con los experimentalistas.
Pero, sobre todo, a través de la robótica
donde intentamos crear nuestros propios sistemas colectivos
que puedan hacer el tipo de cosas como en la naturaleza,
o al menos intentarlo.
Una de nuestras primeras misiones robóticas en esta línea
fue crear nuestra propia colonia de mil robots.
Robots muy simples,
pero que podrían ser programados para exhibir inteligencia colectiva,
y eso es lo que pudimos hacer.
Así que así es como se ve un robot.
Es bastante pequeño, del tamaño de una moneda,
y se puede programar cómo se mueven,
pero también pueden comunicarse inalámbricamente con otros robots,
y puede medir las distancias entre ellos.
Ahora podemos empezar a programar exactamente una interacción,
una regla de juego entre vecinos.
Y una vez que tengamos este sistema,
podemos empezar a programar diferentes tipos de reglas de juego.
como se vería en la naturaleza.
Así, por ejemplo, una sincronización espontánea,
cómo aplaude el público y de repente empiezan a aplaudir juntos,
las luciérnagas brillando juntas.
Podemos programar reglas para la formación de patrones,
cómo las células en un tejido
determinar qué papel van a asumir
y fijar los patrones del cuerpo.
Podemos programar reglas para la migración,
y de esta manera, aprendemos de las reglas de la naturaleza.
Pero también podemos ir un paso más allá.
Podemos tomar las reglas que hemos aprendido de la naturaleza
y combinarlas y crear conductas colectivas completamente nuevas
propiamente nuestras.
Así que, por ejemplo,
imaginen tener dos tipos diferentes de reglas.
La primera regla es una de moción
donde un robot en movimiento puede moverse alrededor de otros estáticos.
Y la segunda regla es una regla patrón
en que un robot toma el color de sus dos vecinos más cercanos.
Así que si empiezo con una pizca de robots en una pequeña semilla patrón.
resulta que estas dos reglas son suficientes para que el grupo
pueda autoensamblarse en un simple patrón de líneas.
Y si las reglas son más complicadas,
y diseño reglas de corrección de errores,
realmente podemos crear ensambles muy complejos,
que se ven así.
Así que aquí, van a ver miles de robots
que trabajan juntos para ensamblar la letra K.
La K está tumbada.
Y lo importante es que nadie está al mando.
Así que cualquier robot solo habla a un pequeño número de robots cercanos,
y usa su regla de moción para moverse
buscando un lugar para encajar basado en sus reglas del patrón.
Y aunque ningún robot hace nada perfectamente,
las reglas son tales que podemos conseguir colectivamente lograr el objetivo
sólidamente juntos.
Y la ilusión se convierte en casi tan perfecta, saben...
que uno empieza a no darte cuenta de que son robots individuales
y se convierten en una sola entidad,
como el banco de peces.
Estos son robots y reglas en dos dimensiones,
pero también podemos pensar en robots y reglas en tres dimensiones.
¿Y si pudiéramos crear robots que podrían construir juntos?
Y para eso podemos inspirarnos en los insectos sociables.
Si piensan en termitas que construyen montículos
o en ejércitos de hormigas.
que crean estructuras increíblemente complejas de nidos de barro
e incluso de sus propios cuerpos.
Y como el sistema que mostré antes,
estos insectos en realidad también tienen reglas de patrón
que les ayudan a determinar qué construir,
pero el patrón puede hacerse de otros insectos
o de barro.
Y podemos usar la misma idea para crear reglas para robots.
Así que aquí pueden ver algunos robots simulados.
donde el robot simulado tiene reglas para moverse
con las que atraviesa la estructura,
buscando un lugar para encajar,
y tiene reglas de patrón donde se examinan grupos de bloques
para decidir si colocar o no un bloque.
Y con las correctas reglas de moción y de patrón
podemos conseguir que los robots construyan lo que queramos.
Y por supuesto, todo el mundo quiere su propia torre.
(Risas)
Así que cuando tengamos esas reglas,
podemos empezar a crear los robots que sigan las reglas.
Vean un robot que puede trepar los bloques,
pero también puede levantarlos y moverlos
y puede editar la propia estructura donde está.
Pero con estas reglas,
en realidad, este es solo uno de los cuerpos imaginables
Pueden imaginarse diferentes tipos de cuerpos.
Si piensan en robots que mueven sacos de arena
para ayudar a construir diques,
o en robots que construyen con materiales blandos
trabajando juntos para apuntalar un edificio derrumbado...
el mismo tipo de reglas en diferentes tipos de cuerpos.
O si, como en mi grupo, completamente obsesionados con ejércitos de hormigas,
quizás algún día podamos hacer robots que trepen sobre cualquier cosa
incluyendo a miembros de su tribu,
y ensamblar cosas de sus propios cuerpos.
Una vez conocidas las reglas,
se hacen posibles muchos tipos diferentes de visiones de robots.
Y volviendo al viaje con esnórquel,
realmente entendemos mucho de las reglas usadas por los bancos de peces.
Así que si podemos inventar los cuerpos que vayan con eso,
tal vez haya un futuro
en el que mi grupo pueda nadar con peces creados por nosotros.
Cada uno de los sistemas que les mostré
nos acerca a tener las herramientas matemáticas y conceptuales
para crear nuestras propias versiones del poder colectivo,
permitiendo muchas clases diferentes de futuras aplicaciones.
Ya bien si piensan en robots que construyen barreras contra inundaciones
o en colonias de abejas robóticas que podrían polinizar los cultivos
o escuelas submarinas de robots que monitorizan los arrecifes de coral,
o si tratamos de alcanzar las estrellas y pensamos en programar
constelaciones de satélites.
En cada uno de estos sistemas,
ser capaz de entender cómo diseñar las reglas del juego
y ser capaz de crear buena conducta colectiva
son clave para hacer cumplir estas visiones.
Hasta ahora he hablado sobre normas para insectos y peces
y para robots,
¿y de las reglas que se aplican a nuestro propio colectivo humano?
El último pensamiento que me gustaría dejarles
es que la ciencia es, por supuesto, ella misma
una manifestación increíble de la inteligencia colectiva,
pero a diferencia de los hermosos bancos de peces que estudio,
siento que todavía nos queda un gran camino evolutivo por recorrer.
Así que además de trabajar para mejorar la ciencia de los robots colectivos,
también trabajo en la creación de robots y pensar en las reglas
que mejorarán nuestra propia colectividad científica.
Hay un dicho que me encanta:
quien hace ciencia determina lo que la ciencia produce.
Imaginen una sociedad
con reglas de juego
donde cada niño puede crecer pensando que puede estar aquí
y ser un tecnólogo del futuro,
o donde cada adulto
crea tener la habilidad no solo para entender, sino para cambiar
cómo la ciencia y la tecnología impactan en su vida cotidiana.
¿Cómo sería esa sociedad?
Creo que podemos hacerlo.
Creo que podemos elegir nuestras reglas,
y nosotros como ingenieros no solo diseñamos robots,
sino podemos hacer crear nuestro propio colectivo humano,
y si lo hacemos y cuando lo hagamos, será hermoso.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)